well uh welcome back everyone
um it's great to see you all
um so we are going to start today with
um
with um with this um colloquium by by
chinmei okay
um so Chennai
um just finished his PhD at Berkeley and
uh he's now
moved on to a job at he's now working at
IBM research
um I guess at the at the Outpost in
Boston which is which seems like a very
nice uh very nice place so um so
um
uh was recently you know he recently
after working at it for a very long time
resolved this um this long-standing
conjecture by Friedman and Hastings
called the nlts conjecture and
um he'll tell us all about it looking
forward to your talk
okay
um yeah thank you thank you so much uh
and let me just say uh firstly that this
is a very much a joint effort with good
friends anuraganshu and Nico Brookman
um and so you know ah
um
so to start
the talk maybe the first place to start
is by sort of understanding classical
proofs
so you know classically in computer
science we think of this very simple
idea of non-deterministic polynomial
time or proofs
where NP is the class of all efficiently
polynomial time checkable proofs and you
know the beautiful thing from computer
science that we've learned is that this
seems like a very monstrous object but
it sort of Can Be Tamed nicely it can be
taped nicely in the sense that it has
complete problems and the complete
problem that we're sort of interested in
is the constraint satisfaction problem
it sort of says hey you know every time
you have something which has
uh can be described by checking a proof
you can instead convert it into a
version of this constraint satisfaction
problem
so what does that mean really it says
okay well the proof you can always write
down as a sequence of bits and what
you're doing to check that the proof is
correct is you perform a bunch of local
checks each local check looks at a small
constraint on a small number of bits so
for example here you could say hey let's
just check if the parity of these three
bits is even
and then together we have all these
local checks each is you know looking at
a different part of it and then you have
this local to Global phenomenon which
says if I consider combining all these
checks all together and now I have a
function that takes big long strings n
bit strings and you know decides how
many checks I'm satisfying then it's NP
hard to decide
if there exists some
assignment to these bits such that all
the checks are satisfied or is if it's
the case that they're for all
assignments at least some check is
violated so this really beautiful way
just to think about NP and just
one problem one way of looking at proofs
right and classical proofs were just the
start of a very long line in computer
science of understanding the complexity
and in particular there are two
extensions that are worth noting today
the first is the Quantum extension which
is the class qma also known as Quantum
Merlin Arthur in which now the proof
instead of being a sequence of classical
bits is now a collection of qubits that
are entangled so it's a Quantum proof in
the very sense that all the proof itself
is a Quantum state
and the first thing to note that is if
you have a Quantum proof it's going to
necessitate a Quantum verifier in order
to sort of understand
what makes this proof more powerful than
its classical counterpart
it has to be read by some Quantum
verifier
and just like constraint satisfaction
problems provided this sort of canonical
complete problem
for NP there's a canonical complete
problem for qma and this was discovered
by kitayov and it says Hey calculating
the ground energy of a local hamiltonian
which is a very Central object in
condensed matter physics it's a complete
problem so if if you could decide if you
could figure out what the ground energy
for generic local hamiltonian systems
were you have a way of solving every
problem that's in qma
what is a local hamiltonian a local
hamiltonian is a linear
uh it's defined by a hamiltonian terms
Each of which is a linear local operator
so just like we had the constraint
satisfaction problem acting on a few of
the bits we could have a a term like
this which is in this case the projector
onto the state zero zero zero and one
one one it's a linear operator that
um
and you can combine all these local
small linear operators and you get a
nice big Global function on the entire
State space and that we describe uh we
write here as a bold H and this bold H
you know is this hamiltonian and there's
a very simple important thing that we
need to understand about the hamiltonian
is that it's sort of a map from States
to an energy to a to a real number and
that's just the map that takes the state
PSI to uh the expectation of PSI on H
that's the energy of the system
and the qma complete problem again is
just calculating the ground energy so
what is the ground energy
so the ground energy is the minimum
eigen value of this Matrix H or another
way of saying it is if you minimize over
all states of this energy function the
ground energy in the same way that in
the constraint satisfaction problem we
were trying to figure out whether there
exists an assignment such that c of x
equals zero here we can say that it's
qma hard to decide
if the ground energy of this hamiltonian
is less than a or greater than b where A
and B are some constants that differ by
a small inverse polynomial amount so in
the CSP case we had that B minus a
equaled one here we can sort of adjust
it a little bit and we get B minus a
equals 1 over poly and this is sort of
an artifact of the proof but morally the
the
idea is roughly the same
now
what this tells us actually is that
ground states of local hamiltonians sort
of form a canonical notion of a proof
for all of qma because what did we say
we said hey you know qma has this
complete problem this is local
hamiltonian problem and calculating the
ground energy is what's really important
and how could someone prove to a to a to
a verifier that some hamiltonian has low
energy well what they literally do is
they provide this ground state they
provide the state of minimal energy and
then the verifier can check the state on
this hamiltonian construct an estimation
of the energy and verify lo and behold
weather was really a low Energy System
state or not
so it's saying something very powerful
that these ground states of local
hamiltonians which are you know very
natural objects it's steady if you think
of a condensed matter physics that they
actually play a very important role in
computer science there's sort of this
canonical notion of proof
and now comes an additional pickle
that is unique to the quantum situation
that doesn't come from the classical is
that because we widely believe that NP
does not equal Q me in fact what we
widely believe is that you know problems
that are qma complete if they if you
were to provide a classical witness it
would have to be super polynomial in
length the polynomial length classical
Witnesses classical proofs just don't
cut it for qma
then we get the surprising phenomenon
that the ground states of local
hamiltonians should not be classically
describable in an efficiently checkable
manner
so what does that mean
um it means
that you you know that these ground
States there's no way that I could for
all local hamiltonians there shouldn't
be any way I could describe to you the
ground state in a way that convinces you
that it is a ground state
you know
um it's sort of that sounds a little
complicated but what you could always
say is
I
I shouldn't have
um
an easy description that polynomial bits
just can't describe this state
and so this is sort of the first
indication that qma is sort of a you
know it's a different Beast than NP that
something
has to occur that you know separate
these two and if you're a skeptic that
qamid is not equal NP that you know you
think that these classes are probably
the same then this black box statement
is sort of a Target that I've painted on
the back
of the class qma which you could attack
you could prove that all ground states
of local hamiltonians indeed they can be
described classically then you'd sort of
collapse these two classes together and
you would prove that NP equals qma so
that's you know
uh a natural thing as a computer as a
complexity theorist to think about
okay but let's put that to the side for
a second and let's think about the other
extension of NP that also happened over
the same sort of time frame which is
probably
probabilistically checkable proofs
so probably
probabilistically checkable proofs
come from this idea that we naturally
think of proofs as requiring
step-by-step checking you know if you
have a paper that you're reading and you
want to make sure that every line is
correct the only way we usually do is we
say did line 10 follow from line nine
did line nine fall from line eight
et cetera et cetera and all the way at
the beginning you need to start with
some assumption that we believe and the
final step has to be you know the answer
so proofs are in some sense
as we usually think of them as
incredibly brittle objects even if you
break at the smallest location the whole
thing can become incorrect
this notion of brittleness of proofs was
sort of was shattered entirely by the
PCP theorem which is this Landmark Crown
Jewel of theoretical computer science
which said that actually every NP
problem you know more the every proof
you can always re
-constructed you can convert it into a
form
such that you only need to read a
constant number of bits in order to be
confident with very high probability in
its validity so that so it says you
don't anymore have to read line by line
you in fact just can read some random
section of the proof and if the random
section of the proof satisfies
uh some local conditions then with high
probability you'll be confident that the
proof is correct
now this might seem rather miraculous
but there's another formulation that's
worth thinking about which is the PCP
theorem you could rewrite it in the
following sense you could say it's NP
hard to decide
if either the the constraint
satisfaction problem was completely
decidable completely excuse me
completely satisfiable as in there
exists a solution which satisfied all
the checks
or
for all solutions
um at least half the checks were
violated
so it might be worth taking a second
here to realize why this second
formulation is actually equivalent to
the first so let's think of it this way
imagine I have a solution x a proposed
solution X in front of me and I want to
decide whether I'm in situation one or
two so if I'm in situation one no matter
which clause I look at
it'll always satisfy that Clause because
CX equals zero right whereas if I'm in
situation two
I will satisfy a clause with that most
fifty percent probability
so in some sense what this is is saying
if I pick a random clause and check it's
like deciding if I have a coin that
always comes up heads versus a coin that
comes up heads at most fifty percent of
the time and you know how many flips
does it take to distinguish a coin that
always comes up heads from a coin that
comes up heads 50 of the time it takes a
constant number of checks in order to be
99 confident so it gives you this very
fast way
of checking if a proof is correct or
false
but there's another consequence of the
of the PCP theorem that's worth thinking
about which is that no longer do I
actually have to
get an exact solution proof
the exact solution proof the x that
satisfies all the checks is actually not
necessary in fact a noisy proof is even
sufficient what do I mean by that
I mean that imagine instead I gave you
an X which satisfied not all the checks
but 75 percent of the checks if the CX
is at most M over four right so if I
have an X that satisfies most of checks
I can still probabilistically verify
this with const number of queries why is
this the case well it's the case because
in the first situation
it's a coin that comes up heads at least
75 of the time right that's what that
would mean if you satisfy 75 of the
checks and in the second situation you
have a coin that comes up heads at most
fifty percent of the time so you have
these coins which have a very different
probability of coming up heads and again
a const number of flips would convince
you of One Versus the other
so the PCP theorem is saying not only
that
you know you can really quickly check
proofs but it's also saying that our
notion of proofs from being this
statement that exactly satisfies every
constraint can now be adjusted to being
something that satisfies most of the
constraints even that is a proof of
validity for NP statements
and this is sort of shattering
maybe because now we can take these two
ideas together
um
and we can start to develop some notion
of quantum pcps so the quantity PCP is
an open conjecture and it says that just
like the classical PCB conjecture it
should be the case that every qma
problem every Quantum proof you can
always convert it into a form so that
you only need to read a constant number
of the qubits in order to be convinced
that the proof was either correct or
false so we sort of combined these two
ideas of qma where the proof is not
Quantum with this idea of PCP where you
only have to read a const number of bits
to check
the other way of saying this would be to
say that it's
cuming hard to decide the energy of a
local hamiltonian to a very large
Precision what Precision it's saying
actually even deciding what the first
few bits of the energy is that's hard
it's saying you can't even tell if it's
completely satisfiable or if any system
must violate a good fraction of the
check some Epsilon fraction of the
checks that would be the quantum PCP
conjecture
but now just like the PCP conjecture
we're we have to witness something sort
of wild
which is that every state of energy
Epsilon over 2 times m
that's also a valid proof right because
just in the same the same analogy I made
about coins Works in this Quantum
setting it's saying that these noisy
Quantum proofs are also proofs that a
Quantum state has low beta excuse me
that a hamiltonian has a low energy
ground state
so our notion of proofs in the quantum
setting if you believe the quantum PCP
conjecture has to expand from just being
the exact ground states of these
hamiltonians to now being all noisy
States
all solutions that violate even a small
fraction of the checks these are all
valid proofs of the quantum statement
and the number of proofs that violate a
small fraction of checks uh have low
energy with this hamiltonian is much
much larger than the this uh size of the
ground space right it's a much bigger
set so
proving you know qma is separate from NP
is now a much much harder task because
they're just more proofs to consider
so let's put these ideas together so the
first one was that when
in the widely believed world that NP is
separate from qma
we have that Quantum proofs cannot be
classically described
in an efficiently checkable Manner and
the second was that
if you if the quantum PCB conjecture is
true that these low energy states of the
quantum PCP uh local hamiltonians
they're also valid proofs because
they're noisy
right so together you get this fact that
if the quantum PCB conjecture is true
that there have to exist local
hamiltonians with no succinct or
efficiently uh describable
classical descriptions for any low
energy state that all the low energy
states that these uh local hamiltonians
must require a lot of com must be very
hard to describe classical
so we've now painted a Target on the
back of the quantum PCP conjecture which
says okay if you don't believe the
quantum PhD conjecture then I invite you
to disprove this box statement to show
that every local hamiltonian has a
simple classical description for some
low energy state if you're able to do
that then you would disprove the quantum
PCB conjecture outright
and this you know is a sort of a amazing
consequence of this Quantum of the
quantum PCB conjecture and it's exactly
where as a skeptic we should you know
look to see if this is true or false in
fact it's sort of the starting point as
to where
we should try to look to see if we can
find the proof of the quantum PCB
conjecture
because the quantum PCB conjecture has
been long-standing for almost two
decades now with you know not an insane
amount of ideas towards how to prove it
correctly so maybe it's false maybe the
way they even proof that it's false is
to prove this statement
sorry excuse me to disprove this
statement
trouble is this statement is really
really hard to disprove or proof
and that's because
the space of classical descriptions is
an insanely vast space if it's very hard
to sort of gather get a leash on what
that exactly means so maybe we even have
to go a little simpler so what we can
say is let's let's think of a very
simple class first of classical
descriptions for Quantum States
I I claim right now that um constant
Quantum circuits form such descriptions
so any state that is describable as the
output of a constant depth Quantum
circuit that serves as a classically
checkable proof
okay
and I I promise you that you know in
about five to ten minutes I will
actually exactly prove this statement
but if I say okay let's just start with
this this is some notion of classical
descriptions
what does it imply well it implies this
actually long-standing open conjecture
called the no low energy trivial States
conjecture this is first written by uh
Friedman and Matt Hastings who who will
be on the panel um after this and it
said
you know that actually there should
exist local hamiltonians so they said no
low energy state is the output of a
constant up circuit so it's saying this
exact statement that was we made a
second ago but we're replacing the
notion of classical descriptions with
this very specific classical description
and this conjecture was made in
um you know 2013 and then published in
2014.
um
and it also withstood for nearly a
decade as being open where we didn't
really have any idea of hamiltonians
which sort of demonstrated this
and did this you know let's let's just
remark that this statement is not saying
anything about computation we sort of
removed computation from the perspective
and we've extracted a statement just
about entanglement about the complexity
of the ground state entanglement
and that sits by itself as sort of an
open conjecture to First either prove or
disprove
so again why is it
fundamentally interesting well if it's
false it sort of trivially disproves the
quantum PCP conjecture
and second it's also making a a
statement about physically realizable
robust entanglement it's it's saying you
know actually if there were hamiltonians
which satisfied this property they sort
of demonstrated different
uh they're they're they're exotic in
some sense they're they're very
different than the hamiltonians we
usually consider it's asking us to
engineer hamiltonians which have a
robust notion of uh entanglement
sorry was there a question I thought I
heard some background chatter
um
Okay so
so this is actually exactly what we
proved in our paper with anurag anshu
and Nico Brookman
which is that this state that the nlts
conjecture is true you can construct
local hamiltonians uh for which no low
energy state is the output of a constant
up circuit and what we actually show is
a little bit of a stronger statement we
show that
most and I'll say with an asterisk for
now which I which I will you know
elaborate and do course most codes most
optimal linear rate and distance codes
Quantum error correcting codes they
correspond to nlts hamiltonians they all
have this robust property uh
uh for the ground space and the low
energy space
another way of saying it is we show that
there exists some Epsilon some constant
and a hamiltonian family H these
correspond to codes so that every state
Pure or mixed of energy less than
Epsilon n you can actually convincingly
prove that any Quantum circuit that
generated that state
or gender to any state that was even
close to it would require log n depth to
generate so this is not the output of a
constant depth circuit
and recall that constant of circuits
I've claimed are classically
checkable proofs they sort of uh if if
you have a state that's the output of a
constant up circuit it's not really a
Quantum object it's really a classical
object and I will prove that in a second
so the rest of my talk is sort of going
to be an explanation of how we got to
this result how we prove this result and
where all the Big Ideas come from that
are required to prove this theorem so
my claim it might be a little lofty is
that if I convince you of three sort of
Big Ideas that the proof just sort of
comes together once you understand these
three ideas
and the first of which is that trivial
states which are in other words saying
states that the output of constant of
circuits they sort of imply a very
special class of local hamiltonians and
using that it's very easy to prove
circuit depth or amounts which is what
we're trying to improve we're trying to
prove that all these states
uh cannot be generated by load up
circuits
the second thing we're going to sort of
need to understand is what the low
energy Subspace of error correcting
codes looks like and there's some very
nice pictures and if you think if you
understand the pictures the rest will
come together
and the third thing that we need to
understand is sort of what happens when
you think about Quantum error correction
how what is special about Quantum error
correction that doesn't exist in
classical error correction and how does
that you know lead to this nlts property
so I claim that if I give you these
three tools sort of the proof will come
together very quickly
foreign
might be a good time to pause
any of the chat
so let's start with the first one let's
let's sort of understand what trivial
States mean states to the output of
circuits and what that means for
hamiltonians and circuit depth
so what I'm going to prove to you is
actually I'm going to prove to you this
this uh onsets I asked you to believe
that low debt states are classical
Witnesses for the energy
okay and so how will I prove this
so
here's the first thing to think about it
said okay if I have an operator a
and I sandwich it between a Quantum
circuit and this let's think of this
Quantum circuit as low depth of depth T
where T is going to be some constant
so then
what do I know about the operator that's
U dagger a u well first of all what is U
dagger Au this is the time evolution of
the operator a across the circuit U so
if my computation is evolving according
to you
you dagger Au is the evolution of this
operator according to
um
according to this unitary
and the first thing to notice is that
when the circuit is low depth the
operator you dagger Au doesn't expand
like crazy
its size is actually bounded
its size is going to be bounded by 2 to
the T times a
why will it be 2 to the T times a well I
think of these circuits as being made up
of two local unitaries two local Gates
on each layer and I'm not going to
specify anything about the connectivity
of the circuit it could be all to all
connectivity
so every time sort of there's a
information light tone that's going
starting from where the operator is
acts and going out into the quantum
circuit and at each level the light
cones sort of can expand by a
multiplicative factor of two
but what I get is that
the description of U dagger AU
is equal to the description of U dagger
Au restricted to the light cone and this
is a very simple reason to see that if I
have a unitary or a gate that sort of
sits outside the light column like these
ones in Orange
if I was to look at a sandwich operator
it sits directly opposite its conjugate
so it just cancels so this whole
computation is going to simplify to just
the computation on the like cone and so
then I can just think of that as one big
unitary that acts on 2 to the T times a
cubits
right
and now if I'm given a local hamiltonian
H and a state which is the out which is
the output of a load up circuit U I
claim I can actually exactly calculate
the energy of PSI with the hamiltonian
In classical time that scales 2 to the 2
to the T but I'm going to think of t as
a constant times polynomial and n okay
so why is that the case well here's how
you could say it so that hamiltonian
it's a linear operation some of all
these local terms so I can just write
that the energy calculation in terms of
each of these local terms but now
I take PSI and I write it as U times
zero right you applied to zero and what
I get now is that I get a computation
that acts on two to the T qubits
but if it's a computation that acts in
two of the T qubits I can just Brute
Force calculate that with the classical
computer in time 2 to the 2 to the T
so therefore I have an algorithm for
computing the energy exactly in time 2
to the 2 to the T
times polynomial
n where n is the number of cubits
and this is exactly to prove that you
know these load up States they are
classical Witnesses for energy because
whenever there is a load up State I
don't need to you know provide the state
itself as a proof I can install it
instead provide the circuit that
generates the state and a classical
computer can actually check whether that
circuit was yielding a state of low
energy or not
so this is why the nlts ethereum is so
powerful at saying these classical
Witnesses these consonant circuits just
cannot cut it for the class of
hamiltonians we're about to construct
right so far so good have I
uh any more questions
the next thing I'm going to need to tell
you
is sort of
that we need to understand these states
these consonant States uh a little
better
so let's just think about the following
simple thought experiment which isn't
the state zero it's the unique solution
to a very simple local hamiltonian
and what's that hamiltonian it's just
this hamiltonian which qubit by qubit IT
projects
away from zero right it projects onto
the one space so this is the hamiltonian
whose unique ground state is the all
zero state
and it's a very simple Hamilton and it's
very easy to analyze it's a commuting
hamiltonian it has a spectrum which is
all integers and the eigenvectors uh are
just the basis vectors their eigenvalues
are just their hammingways right very
simple hamiltonian we understand it too
well almost
okay but now let's think about what
happens if I take this hamiltonian and I
rotate it
or evolve it by a unitary U
right let's call this H2 well because
it's evolved it by a unitary
I get that hu has to have the same
Spectrum
well what will happen is that the
eigenvectors themselves will change the
eigenvectors will be U applied to the
original eigenvectors which are just for
basis vectors right
and let's notice something which is that
this hamiltonian hu it has a unique
ground state and that ground fit is
exactly the state which is U applied to
zero right so this load up state which
is U applied to zero is the unique
ground state of this hamiltonian Hu
but let's top it off by saying that hu
as a hamiltonian is a local hamiltonian
its locality is exactly two to the T and
its locality is 2 to the T just by the
same light cone argument we used a slide
earlier and so now what we have is that
all our load up States
they correspond to local hamiltonians in
a very natural way
and now this actually turns out to be
enough for us to prove some simple
Notions of Circa depth lower bounds
foreign
so what I'm going to show in a second is
that if you have two states which are
what are called locally
indistinguishable then they have there's
a simple argument to prove that these
states cannot be the output of load up
circuits or in other words every if I
can prove that a state is locally
indistinguishable
I actually have a very rigorous argument
for a circuit depth lower bound
so what does it mean for two states to
be locally indistinguishable well two
states are going to be locally
indistinguishable if for all reduced
density matrices of size d the marginal
States the reduced States on those on
those small regions are identical
so maybe an example is illustrative
the chaos states which are the
uh hello
the cat states which are the
you know also known as the GHz state
which are the superposition of all zeros
and all ones with a sign either a plus
or minus these two states are locally
indistinguishable from each other
they're actually n minus one locally
indistinguishable and this isn't too
hard to realize one can simply just
check and calculate what the reduced
density Matrix would be on any n minus
one qubits and it actually is a very
simple the reduced density Matrix sort
of just loses the sign it just becomes
the mixture the classical mixture of
either all zeros or all ones
so now I'm going to prove a circuit
depth lower bound given just this fact
of being D locally and distinguishable
so here's what I'll explain I'll claim
that if two states are be locally
indistinguishable
then any circuit that generates either
state must require at least log depth
log D depth okay so how will I prove
this well we we haven't developed too
many tools so far so let's just use all
the ones we know
so what's the first thing we're going to
do well we we're going to use a
hamiltonian what's a good hamiltonian to
use well we've spent some time on the
previous slide generating the
hamiltonian hu this hamiltonian whose
unique ground state is the state's PSI
right and I'm gonna I'm gonna just
consider the thought experiment which is
what is the energy of PSI Prime with
this hamiltonian Hu
well I can write H2 as a sum of local
terms h i
but then what I'm going to see is that
the energy of h i with PSI Prime is
exactly equal to the energy of h i with
PSI and these energies are going to be
equal
because h u
is the local hamiltonian
but these states are locally
indistinguishable on larger regions than
the size of each of the locality of Hu
H so what that's saying in fact this is
where the term locally and
distinguishable comes from it's saying
that the hamiltonian hu cannot
differentiate the state's PSI Prime and
PSI they are identical to to this
hamiltonian
which means that the energy
is exactly equal to the energy
of h u with PSI which is zero
so I get that both PSI Prime and PSI are
ground states of this hamiltonian Hu
H but the point I uh hopefully stressed
earlier was that the hamiltonian hu has
a unique ground state
it has a unique ground state which is
PSI
so now I have this contradiction right
that I have the I have a hamiltonian
which has two ground states which are
not unique and the only way that could
happen is if PSI equals PSI Prime and
there's our contradiction so this tells
me that you know
if I if I can find local and
distinguishability it's a way of proving
Circa depth or balance
so in some sense my my new my chart my
I've shifted the goal posts a little bit
originally when we talked about nlts we
said okay we want to prove Circa depth
lower bounds for all the low energy
states and now in some sense I'm saying
really the way to go about doing this is
we first find local and
distinguishability and then we sort of
prove a little more about that so we
should go looking for where local
indistinguishability occurs
but before we go out about you know
Finding local and distinguishability
there's one thing to note
which is that this Lemma here isn't it's
very brittle and the the thing we don't
want is any business we sort of want
robustness that's the whole idea of this
exercise and pcps and and LPS is all
about robustness right
well in order to use this Lemma I needed
that PSI and PSI Prime were exactly
locally indistinguishable which means
that on all local regions that reduce
density matrices were exactly equal
but what if I don't have that what if I
have that on the reduced density
matrices are approximately equal to one
another
or on that most Regions they're exactly
equal what if you know like how if I
just you know shift this a little bit
add a little noise does the same
statement hold well the problem is that
this
this argument on the previous slide it
really the Crux was that there was a
unique ground state and you can make it
a little bit robust but you can't make
it too robust because the spectral gap
of this hamiltonian was really small it
was one
so what that turns it out to be in terms
of robustness is it's robust to small
perturbations of order one over n so it
says any state in a small very minuscule
ball around PSI and PSI Prime
must also have high uh circuit
complexity but it's not saying anything
about like a constant sized baller on
sine cybering which is something we
definitely need
so first thing we'll have to do is sort
of we need to take this lever which is
allowing us to prove circuit depth lower
bounds and make it a little bit more
robust
and so this is where we can use some
math from shabby Chef polynomials
and we can prove this this theorem I
present in front of you
don't read it for a second just uh
listen to me for a split second and then
we can go through it so what is it
saying it's going to say that if I have
a distribution on the Boolean hypercube
and this distribution puts Mass on two
regions well I'll call X1 and S2
and these regions in the Boolean hybrid
Cube are far apart from each other
then any Quantum circuit that generates
this distribution and you can think of
that as you apply a Quantum circuit and
then you measure in the standard basis
or in the hadamard basis
any Quantum circuit that generates this
distribution must have required
log depth to generate log n depth
to generate the formal version is what's
written here but that this is morally
what you want to think of so this is
sort of saying that the cat State
example I previously said for local
indistinguishability I can make that
robust
so recall the cat saves the state which
has
half Mass on the Zero State and half
Mass on the all one state and what we're
saying here is well we can actually make
that robust in the following sense the
mass no longer needs to be half and half
on both parts as long as it's any small
constant mu that's okay as long as it's
bounded away from zero
and
furthermore I don't need that the mass
to be on these points exactly of the
Boolean hypercube as long as there's
some regions
S1 and S2 that I can generate
I can prove this lower bound
so this is sort of the robust version of
the lower bound we stated previously
given local and distinguishable
there's a simple proof sketch on how one
might do this well we want to use the
local indistinguishability ideas we just
stated but we're going to have to make
them a little bit more approximate so
what we say is if there was a state PSI
which generated this distribution
then you could always find some region R
which encapsulates S2
so that if I considered the state PSI
Prime where what I do is I take PSI and
I just flip the side on all the parts
that are in R so I get two states sine
PSI Prime that these states
are approximately locally
indistinguishable
and then I sort of use the same
ideas that we did in the previous slide
to massage this into a circuit depth
lower back
so the theorem I have here in front of
you is sort of the backbone behind how
we're going to prove the nlts result we
need some way of arguing Circa depth
lower bound and what we're going to say
is if I can prove that I generate
distributions that's you know that look
like this then I have uh this must have
come from a high def circuit
so let's let's give these distributions
a name for the Simplicity of the
Aristotle is called them well spread
and what does it mean in Context of nlts
it says well okay if you want to prove
the nlts result you what you need to do
is you need to show that there exists a
local hamiltonian whose entire low
energy space so every state of low
energy
if measured in either the x or the Z
basis it's going to induce such a
well-spread distribution such a
well-spread classical distribution
so again now we we just keep we're all
we're doing this whole talk is we're
just going to slightly move the goal
post as we narrow in towards something
that's a little bit more tractable so
now we have a Target here which is we
want to find well spread distributions
what we're going to keep in mind that
all this idea is about local and
distinguishability and
are still very relevant and you know
should sort of spearhead how we think
about these things
okay so now we get to part two of The
Talk which is where where are we going
to find such well spread distributions
and the best place to look for them I
claim is an error correction in fact we
can start to see that well spread
distributions appear
by just looking at classical error
correction
the classical error correction is a very
you know well-studied field many people
know it a lot better than I will ever
but
the thing one should think about is that
in classical error correction you have
this notion of a linear code
the linear code is the kernel of some
check Matrix so just the Boolean Matrix
H and we're looking at all solutions
and what I claim that all you need from
classical error correction is the
following picture
which is that if I have a low energy
State a state that violates a few of the
checks of this classical error
correcting code
what does that space look like what is
the space of states that violate few
checks look like so first things to note
is that the space that violates a few
checks will of course include all the
code Words which are these black dots in
the centers of these clusters
but the second thing to note is that
because we're going to consider local
codes
the regions around the codewords
themselves
these are the regions in Hamming
distance they also will all be low
energy
but sort of the amazing thing is that
with high probability if my code is
expanding or you know it's like from a
myriad of random constructions there'll
also be these extra sort of phantom
clusters that appear
um that I've drawn out here that uh you
know don't contain any original code
word but the amazing fact is that these
clusters sit far apart from each other
so what I get is that the low energy
space of a random classical error
correction code it looks like the
disjoint Union
of a bunch of clusters
and the fun thing about these clusters
is that they're all far apart from each
other the code with high probability is
going to have linear distance and I get
that the distance between all these
clusters is also a linear function of n
so first off this
is the start of what could be a
well-spread distribution
right because I have
that
a lot of regions that are all far apart
from each other so if I
it sort of plays the role for support
for a distribution that we hope to prove
is well spread it says okay look if you
know if I'm only have mass on these uh
Coke on these green regions then my
distribution's on its way to being well
spread the only issue is that I I have
no way of proving that my distribution
isn't concentrated on any one cluster if
I just thought of the hamiltonian that
corresponds to a classical code there's
no way I could prove and it's false
actually that the distribution is well
spread in order to get this well
spreadness property I'm going to need
something a little bit more but the low
energy space of this code is it's a good
start it's a it's the support it's
exactly what we're looking for but it's
not quite there
um to prove you know that
there's a question about from the
audience uh how do we know the existence
of these Phantom clusters that don't
have code words
ah okay so let's let's actually go
through it at a high level
um you can prove that if the if you take
this code and you write down this
adjacency graph that corresponds to it
so that's like this graph between bits
and checks is the graphic small set
expanding
um then it it's actually just this
inherent Factor being small set
expanding that induces these Phantom
clusters and it's not too many
calculations
um and I I don't think we have time
today but that that's really the picture
that if you have this uh small set
expansion you know you could do some
quick light algebra and get to it
um we have it written in our result or
um
it in my thesis if you if someone wants
like a little bit of a closer look at it
yeah the Phantom clusters an intuition
as to why a phantom cluster exists is
perhaps if I take the check Matrix H and
I remove a row entirely so I remove one
of the checks now what I'm going to be
left with is another check Matrix for
with high probability another very good
code but that code is going to have
twice
the dimension that the original code did
so there have to be two times as many
solutions to this guy
and those new Solutions have to be far
apart from all the old Solutions and far
apart from all the new Solutions also
because this is a new code
so those guys are actually the cores of
these new Phantom clusters
so right so we're sort of saying these
Phantom clusters appear because I can
you know move a little bit in Hamming
distance or I could start to remove
checks entirely and violate or I could
do some combination of both and that's
what induces these Phantom clusters
I hope that
helps the ask her the question
okay so so far we you know we've said
that okay we're looking for well
spreadness we sort of see it coming out
of error correction but we don't exactly
see it because all we're getting is
supports of distributions that kind of
look like this we need to now show that
distributions actually are spread so in
order to do that we're going to require
Quantum error correction
and this is where it's helpful to sort
of understand some principal properties
of quantum error correction
so the greatest thing about Quantum
error correction in my purse
I believe is that it corrects Erasure
errors and this is wildly fascinating
so if I have a Quantum error correcting
code
and I remove a correctable region so
this is a region which I was supposed to
be able to correct
um there exists a recovery map from
where I can take the region
where that Erasure error occurred and I
can correct back to get the state
but let's consider the thought
experiment where that erased component I
keep it right I just remove it and then
I apply the recovery map on the other
side so now I have the removed region
and I have the reconstuted state all by
itself
so this this should screen violating no
cloning theorem right away right and the
only resolution of how this doesn't
violate no cloning is that the removed
region contains no information about the
original state
that way I could have just constructed
the removed region all by itself without
uh remove you know without this
procedure
or in other words what it's saying is
that what no matter what code State I
encode in my error correcting code any
correctable region contains absolutely
no information about the encoded state
or in other words that's exactly local
indistinguishability it's saying that
Quantum error correction implies local
indistinguishability for error
correcting codes
so immediately you get that if you have
a Quantum Code of distance D the Exact
Solutions require circuit depth log D to
generate
so this is just to be another indication
that you know thinking about codes was
the right path in order to prove circuit
lower bounds because these Exact
Solutions have this
circuit that blow around that's almost
immediate
right
and furthermore
these Quantum error correcting codes
they actually induce natural local
hamiltonians
and that's just a hamiltonian where
there's a hamiltonian term for every
check that the code has so every
stabilizer check of this code there is a
corresponding hamiltonian term
the open question that we still need to
resolve is how do you prove these
circuit depth or abouts how do you prove
that they the low energy states induced
well spread distributions
so to do that in uh you know the last
minutes what we're going to have to do
is we're gonna have to start thinking
about a specific class of codes and the
very specific class of codes that we
should use are these CSS codes called
America Shore steam codes which sort of
which correct
the two types of uh fundamental errors
bit flips and face flips independently
and the reason why we really want to
think about CSS codes is that thinking
about CSS codes is very useful because
we can understand the induced
distributions of these codes very well
they're really the right way to think
about CSS codes in my opinion is you can
think about what the distributions look
like when I measure code words or low
energy words these CSS codes
so they're constructed from these
classical codes the details here are a
little bit less important but the the
real detail to think about is actually
this picture over here
that if I was to measure the CSS code in
the Z basis
I'm going to get a cluster distribution
I'm going to get measurements that occur
in these blue regions the distance
between these blue regions is actually
the Z distance of the code and sort of
the size of the blue region is
determined by the rate of the xcode so
both these codes their properties are
playing a role in what this distribution
looks like but we're getting a cluster
distribution
so now that we have a cluster
distribution at least just for the
ground States
what we want is hey what happens
in the low energy perspective
so imagine we had a CSS code
where the low energy State looked just
like the previous pictures but sort of
combining the two ideas together that it
clusters just nicely and we have these
clusters that scale around the original
um
code but then maybe these Phantom
clusters also start to pop up but as
long as the distance between all the
Clusters is low
then we're good and what this actually
uh
requires is sort of a notion of
expansion for both the Czech matrices in
the x and z basis and the miraculous
thing is that there's this deep
connection that's going on here between
you know this expansion and the x and z
basis in last year's colloquium we heard
a talk about how to construct linear
rate and linear distance codes and its
connection to the C cubed local
testability conjecture and you know all
these ideas are they're all sort of
facets of the same notion there's
somehow there has to be this deep
expansion going on
and what we right here is sort of uh an
amplification of the notion of distance
um so if we have this sort of Amplified
notion of distance
um we we get a picture that looks like
this
and now what I get is the exact same
thing I said about the support for the
classical picture which is that if I
have a low energy state
when I'm measure in the Z basis I'm
going to get a distribution that is
highly supported on these clusters
that low energy states in the Z basis
the you know that the distribution at
least at the moment has the support of a
well-spread distribution we haven't
proven that it is well spread it has the
support of a well-spread distribution
but the key fact the key differentiator
between what the quantum example that
we're doing now and the classical
example that failed last time was that
in in reality there's actually two
pictures going on there's the picture in
the Z basis drawn here and there's a
picture an identical picture that's
going on in the X basis
and the fact of the matter is that
having the same picture go on in both
bases at the same time is what's going
to be able to prove well spread
distribution
what we're going to show is that either
the induced Z distribution or the X
distribution
of these codes is well spread
we're and we're going to do this with an
uncertainty principle
so that's the next step
so so far we have supports that look
kind of well spread now we need to argue
that they actually
you know really
have mass everywhere
so we want to prove there's sort of a
partition where half the masses on one
side half the masses on the other or not
even half we just need to say that
there's some constant Mass on both sides
of this cup
to do that
all I really need to do is I need to
show that not too much mass let's say 99
of the math is concentrated on any one
cluster because what that will show is
that at least
something like 1 over 400 doesn't really
matter the constants mass is on either
side of some partition
and that will give us our circuit that
lower bound
to do this as I said before we're going
to need to realize that we have to
picture going on the X in the X picture
and the Z picture simultaneously
so what we're going to do is we're going
to say okay let's assume
that the picture was clustered in the Z
picture say then we're going to argue
that it cannot be clustered in the X
picture and that would prove that the X
distribution is well spread
so to do that we need some uncertainty
principle there's a lot of uncertainty
principles just like anti-commutation of
observables here's one about measuring
in the all X or all Z basis it says that
you know if you concentrate in the Z
basis
then you have to be spread in the X
basis that's roughly what this
uncertainty principle says
so we'll apply that we'll say let's
assume that the Z distribution
is concentrated on some Z cluster
then for any X cluster
it's not con it's not concentrated
the way we'll need to do that is we're
going to need to understand what the
sizes of these clusters are to apply
this distribution because there's this
error term in the uncertainty principle
and the size of the cluster is not too
hard to calculate it's sort of
a combination of two numbers right one
is the size of the initial Quantum
object which is this 2 to the RX term
this is the this comes from the CSS fact
and the other one is this combinatorial
term which is sort of the bubbling out
as I consider low energy states
and you can bound this you know by just
some trivial math identities
and likewise you'll get bound on the Z
on the X picture
and so you know you just put these guys
together and you say okay well if I have
99 of my Max on
um
the Z picture
then the amount of mass I have on the X
picture uh is bounded by this result now
note this interesting property that
comes up that you know maybe we'll talk
about a little bit in the panel is why
is this rate term pop up is it we don't
actually uh understand truly if this is
an artifact of the proof or something a
little bit more powerful but but the
rate term pops up here and so what you
get is that you know if your energy
though if you're considering a linear
rate code
as long as the Epsilon that we're
selecting is you know smaller than K
Over N squared then you get this um sort
of well spread distribution in the X
picture as well
so what we've proven to wrap up is we've
said hey
if I measure this Quantum error
correcting code in the x or Z basis at
least one of those pictures has to be
this well spread distribution and that's
going to hold for any low energy State
and that's a combination of expansion
and uncertainty principles
so
to to conclude
what we said is we you know we've sort
of provided all the little ingredients
one is that how does uh well spreadness
provide
um Circa depth lower bounds and you know
we showed that using some simple
examples of local and distinguishability
then we said if you have these codes
with these optimal parameters which you
know took there's a line of work that
reached it but if you have such codes
then is not too much more work to
actually show that they have this nlts
property we sort of combined some simple
ideas about what the induced
distributions look like and we're able
to rigorously argue these circuit at
lower bounds
and
you know the the first thing I'll say
just before we start the panel is
in terms of quantum PCP conjecture you
know you you might ask me what does it
say about this and I'll probably say
that it doesn't say anything about
whether the quantum PCB conjecture is
more likely to be true maybe the right
way to say it is it says it's much
harder to prove it's false now because
this very simple Target that we could
paint on the back of the quantum PCP
conjecture
um no longer holds so if we're going to
disprove it we're going to have to
require some more fancy Machinery than
just constant depth circuits and I'm
sure we'll talk about this more in the
panel in due course
um
so maybe with that Umesh I should
conclude and take some questions and
yeah great uh thanks Jen Matt for a
great talk so uh let's see if there any
questions from the audience and also
China if you stop sharing maybe uh they
can start pinning the
the video the yeah videos of the of the
panelists so so
um let's see are there any any questions
from the audience
please feel free to either speak up or
raise your hands or put it in there I
see some hands raised digitally but I
can't seem to approve them
let me see okay why am I not uh
uh
hi there
um yeah so I have a couple of really
basic questions
um how
um how do these Quantum complexity
problems like the PQ uh qpcp conjecture
um you know correspond to uh you know
very physical things like Hamilton
ground state energies and then kind of
like a follow-up um how does it relate
to the Yang Mal's Yang Mills Mass Gap
problem
please
I can uh certainly answer the first I'm
not actually sure what the Yen Mills Gap
is so maybe not the second
um the first one I can say that these
hamiltonians that we're constructing
they're very engineered objects they in
fact cannot exist on any constant
dimensional lattice hamiltonian so this
isn't sort of the object which uh if you
are you know study
condensed matter physics traditionally
you know where you think about lattices
of spin systems Etc that you would these
are not those types of hamiltonians this
is sort of condensed matter plus plus
it's saying something about what is the
natural computer science extension of
this
um so you know it's not there's not
nothing is coming to break Laboratories
of condensed matter physicists around
the world
this is more of a theoretical idea yeah
yeah okay maybe
Umesh can you comment on the um Yang
Yang Mills Mass cap um theorem is there
any relationship because that's to do
with ground state hamiltonians right or
the spectral Gap
um you know I I'm uh could I'm not sure
um maybe could you could use could you
state a little bit more about it or why
sure I mean I I can just say I don't
think it's really closely related to the
Yang Mills Mass Gap question Daniel's
theories are non-abelian quantum field
theories the mass Gap is essentially uh
in these uh
non-relativistic quantums theories that
we're looking at the mass Gap is
analogous to the spectral gap of the
operator
um you would have to take some kind of
uh Continuum limit in order to say
anything about Yang Mills and that's not
really in the cards here because this is
a discrete finite size thing with the
planet dimensional over spaces in
discrete locations so I don't think
there's really a deep connection with
Daniels
because Yang Mills is obviously one of
the seven Millennial problems so I
thought maybe it would shine some light
on solving that big problem and then you
could get a million dollar prize
but um it doesn't seem like there is
thanks thanks thanks a lot for the
question so